[Music]
have you ever noticed that whenever
you're thrown off center by bad
experience or bad news
or when you're really tired or not
feeling well you automatically fall into
a default emotion
such as fear anxiety despair anger
or sadness it can be exhausting to try
to be creative and productive when
your emotions are dragging you down
after finding myself falling into
despair over and over again for several
years
often with no apparent cause i finally
questioned what was going on
i began to think of this automatic
response as
an emotional habit most of us were
taught emotional habits in our childhood
that made us
emotionally dependent later on in our
adult lives
these are habits that limit our personal
growth such habits creep up on us
without us being aware of it
until we get to a point where nearly
everything triggers the same response
fear grief or anger in this video you
will discover the top habit performing
exercises that have helped me
overcome my mental blocks and negative
emotions they create a more responsible
aware purposeful and accepting person in
me little by little
day by day in simple words they make me
more self-aware and self-confident
i'm sure they can help you too
your brain is already telling you to
skim through these exercises and how it
would be nice to try them one day
maybe you'll email this video to your
friends who you think
might need it more than you do but the
reality is that everyone has some
negative emotional habits that they need
to change
also everyone has excuses that will stop
them from bringing any real change to
their life
so go on write down your list of excuses
this doesn't just work with emotional
habits it works with any habit you know
is sabotaging you but
you just can't help yourself doing it
you already know that the first step is
always
conscious acknowledgement writing
something down
reinforces this conscious
acknowledgement our automatic mental
excuses seem so rational
so real so important until we write them
down
that's just how mental inertia works
habits are always supported by excuses
to keep the mind in a homeostatic state
it's only when you poke it with a stick
that you realize how resistant to change
your mind actually is
you have to upset the balance of this
homeostasis and you do so by attacking
the foundation
it's built on
as you might imagine some of the excuses
you wrote down probably sound silly
the thing however is that there is no
such thing as a silly excuse
i don't buy half of my excuses and
neither should you yours
but most of the excuses you wrote down
have a reason to be there
you are too tired because you didn't
sleep well last night okay
seems reasonable you don't have time
that might also be true
systematically dismissing all excuses in
order to change the mental habit doesn't
really work
the brain will just find a way to come
up with new ones
before long you are caught up in a
circle of inventing excuses and
dismissing them
a better method would be to rank the
validity of those excuses
relative to each other the bottom ones
will just fall out
naturally with the top ones write down
what you need to do to convert those
excuses to action
not enough time what do you need to do
to make time
too tired from doing other important
stuff first what's more important than
your inner peace or your self-confidence
by converting your excuses into action
you're reversing the momentum of your
mental inertia
it's the motivation to act despite
mental inertia that creates positive
mental habits to counteract the bad ones
imagine a place where you go to mentally
that is free of judgment from yourself
and from the world what would it be like
if you have the same feeling in the real
world
where people are constantly stressed and
out of sync with reality
do you feel calm do you feel confident
as dan gilbert pointed out in his book
stumbling on happiness
facts and reality have a way of
prioritizing over imagination in your
brain
it's like a coping mechanism so that we
don't get lost in dreamland and endanger
our lives
however this doesn't mean that you can't
visualize yourself being completely calm
and confident
and slowly working toward becoming this
person every day
the power of visualization allows you to
create some form of rapture
on the fabric of reality through which
you can see your desired future self
eventually no matter how hard reality
hits you
the image of a better future will be
with you even in the midst of the
greatest emotional turmoils
according to research done using brain
imagery visualization works because
neurons in our brains interpret imagery
as equivalent to a real life action
when we visualize an act the brain
generates an impulse that tells our
neurons to
perform the movement and this feels
quite real sometimes
sentence completion is when you start
out with a particular sentence called
the stem
and write a few endings at a time one
example would be to start out with
if i acted a little bit more honestly
today
then you would write six to ten endings
like i would voice my opinion when i
feel it is needed or
i wouldn't feel that i'm always hiding
from something
bar none this method has been the most
effective in my life
i have noticed myself impulsively
becoming more honest in a fashion that
surprises me pleasantly my body
emotional habits are slowly melting away
i no longer feel dejected at any point
in my day
and this mental empowerment affects also
my positivity and overall mood
this will work in any particular arena
of your life and it will definitely
affect your sense of self-esteem
and self-ownership dr nathaniel brandon
who wrote the great book
psychology of self-esteem suggests that
we all have subconscious parts of our
minds
that are constantly striving to grow and
become more self-confident
sentence completion activates these
parts of our minds and
gently nudges them into the direction of
positive mental habits
i found a great explanation of the word
neuroticism in the online therapy
website
talkspace so neuroticism is defined by a
propensity toward anxiety negativity and
self-doubt
it is often experienced by constantly
rehashing
worst case scenarios in our head and it
can be linked to
guilt worry fear and depression
knowing that we have neurotic tendencies
that lead to bad emotional habits
is step one step two would be to catch
them
when they actually surface this requires
an amazing amount of self-awareness and
perhaps some pain
but it's so worth it when you're able to
stop yourself from acting on your
neurotic impulses they start to lose
their powers over you
this is how you start to reassume
control over your life instead of
running from one urge to another when
you have a strong urge to do something
ask yourself if the urge comes from a
neurotic impulse or if it's actually
based on a healthy manifestation of your
personal needs
an easy way to tell is by asking
yourself if you are doing this out of a
negative or positive emotional space
are you doing it out of fear and anger
or out of love and altruism
are you doing it out of a false sense of
justice
or out of a need to collaborate catching
yourself exhibiting neurotic behaviors
is the first step to self-awareness then
you can work towards minimizing their
emergence
and the impact they have on your life
[Music]
in the great book beyond success and
failure i stumbled upon a quite profound
sentence
perhaps the only way to get rid of our
bad mental habits
is to see their ultimate consequences
your brain does two things extremely
well
it seeks pleasure and it avoids pain as
long as your emotional habit is tied to
pleasure
you will perform it when you tie it to
particularly painful experiences however
you will avoid it like the plague a
great parallel would be to imagine
yourself being an alcoholic
if an alcoholic wants to stop drinking
he can't simply abstain from drinking
altogether
this will only intensify his craving he
stops drinking when he comes face to
face with the damage that causes to him
and his loved ones
seeing one's life in shambles can be a
strong motivator for change
bad habits both emotional and normal
became habits when we once needed them
in order to numb
some painful experience it's also
something we run to when things don't go
well in reality
to kick these habits once and for all we
have to come face to face with the
damage they cause us
then and only then the need for change
becomes more powerful
[Music]
it's too easy to lose yourself in this
new information age
you're constantly bombarded with new
ideas about who you're supposed to be
and what you're supposed to do
buried underneath this mountain of
information is the real you
who's striving to grow and has all the
necessary tools to do so
you simply have to become an observer of
your reality
a few times a day practice looking at
yourself in third person
act as if it's another person in your
world who is very important to you
you truly realize what you need to do to
actually make this person get the most
out of this world
a quick and easy way to do this is by
setting reminders to yourself throughout
the day
it allows you to snap out of whatever
information trans you're being caught in
throughout the struggle of life most of
the time we just do things to enhance
our value in the eyes of others
we travel to exotic locations to post
pictures about it to show off to our
friends
we do this because we think that they
value travel relaxation and beautiful
sights
just like us the conundrum is that when
we seek to be visible to others
we become less visible to ourselves this
exercise
makes us realize that if we're already
visible to ourselves
by living in congruence with our values
we no longer need to be that visible to
others
just like old people i'm full of ideas
and thoughts about
what the world should be like and how i
should fit into it
for example i think sometimes that the
world should be more open and friendly
so that
it's easier for me to be myself of
course
the world is too complex to adhere to
such a simplistic view
that's why i practice filtering some of
my thoughts through the what if i'm
wrong filter
to identify bad emotional habits most of
the time you're neither right
nor wrong most ideas and beliefs are
predicated on specific mental frameworks
and circumstances
the benefit of training yourself to
maintain this internal filter
is that you fight the delusional aspect
of your reality
if you start to have self-reproaching
thoughts by questioning them
you can put the brakes on them and turn
them into positive thoughts
if you're driven by some emotion to
react negatively to some matter
by questioning it you can calm yourself
down
such power cannot be understated
you will realize that it's okay to be
wrong being wrong has nothing to do with
your self-respect
being able to correct yourself is
instrumental in being connected to
reality
the yardstick for evaluating the
self-respect of an individual
is not how they act inside their bubble
of beliefs
but how they act when they need to
escape that bubble
[Music]
like most people you will find yourself
in an emotional rat at times
an emotional route is characterized by
having a thought
or emotion that you just can't shake it
haunts your every thought and trying to
escape it is simply a fruitless process
the larger issue here might not be a
mental state but
more like a physical state that you're
in
the body has a specific way of letting
you know it needs to move and create new
experiences
when this happens don't even try to
fight it mentally just attempt to change
your physical environment
by going for a walk outside or tidying
up your room or
redecorating your personal space i find
that simply leaving my place to go
somewhere else with a different
ambience like a coffee shop or a park
changes my mood pretty much instantly
and last for life
starts to feed my body and mind once
again
no matter how immediate and strong an
emotion seems
it is always transient it's the habits
behind these emotions that keep them
coming back
making them seem so important when you
change your physical state
your brain receives two messages first
that you are capable of taking action
in spite of emotions and second that
your perspective can always change
you condition your subconscious mind not
to stay in one mental state and suffer
but to take the initiative no matter how
small and change
purpose is the ultimate form of good
emotional manipulation
my purpose is to create and whenever i
feel anxious sad or angry
if i decide to channel my bad emotions
into something creative
i almost always replace bad feelings
with positive ones
the problem is that most of us don't
feed our sense of purpose habitually
enough
we either do it only when we really need
to or only when we force ourselves to
that way the brain perceives this act as
painful instead of pleasurable
we disengage ourselves emotionally from
the one thing that can save us in the
long run make it a habit to do something
throughout the day that gives you deep
fulfillment
this deep fulfillment is your sense of
purpose and it needs your attention to
grow
each of us has a unique set of values
that strive to adhere to
this drives us to live purposefully and
truthfully
however lacking the capacity to develop
and realize these values
we seek it in others we do this
subconsciously through the emotionally
dependent habits that we learned as
children
we manipulate and get manipulated by
others instead of focusing on changing
our own habits and eventually becoming
self-reliant emotionally independent
people
showcase intent behind their emotional
habits
they need to know that what they do no
matter how boring
painful or difficult in the short term
has a long-term value
this is the quintessence of a
purpose-driven mentality
bad emotional habits are a cry from our
inner child that
seeks to mature and make peace with the
absurdity of the world around us
we don't need to be too harsh with a
child we just need to acknowledge its
existence
and nurture it the way we would like to
be nurtured
you